I've been telling you for weeks and months
that as the pressure mounts around Donald
Trump, he will become more erratic and desperate
and panicked and the public facing expression
of this panic is very likely to be tweets,
endless tweets, tons of tweets, and we're
seeing it.
Donald Trump tweeted 82 times on Saturday,
82 times.
This makes his 10 tweet rants of six months
ago seem comparatively sane and sober now,
what is triggering Trump impeachment, including
the public impeachment inquiry hearings starting
tomorrow, which will be streaming live on
our YouTube channel.
The continued in competence and corruption
of the people around Trump, including Rudy
and Sean Hannity and many others, Trump realizing
that tens of millions of people want him out
and they want them out.
Now, Trump has been heavily triggered and
we're going to look at a few of those tweets
shortly.
We're not going to look at anywhere close
to 82 but some of the themes in salt include
insulting a house intelligence committee chairman
Adam Schiff, tweeting about him 11 times.
Trump, of course likes to claim presidential
harassment against himself, but tweeting 11
times about one Congressman, it sort of sounds
like presidential harassment by the president
rather than of the president of the whistleblower
mentioned 11 times.
Some version of impeachment mentioned nine
times.
Let's take a look at some of Trump's tweets.
A lot of them were actually retweets of various
Fox news segments that Trump determined are
favorable to him.
Sometimes they featured Sean Hannity or others.
Then there were actual tweets that Donald
Trump wrote, like for example, quote, but
the witch hunt continues after three years
of relentless attacks against the Republican
party and me the do nothing.
Dams are losers for America.
One tweet was filled with nicknames.
Trump's saying quote, I recommend that nervous
Nancy Pelosi who backed up shifts lie shift
the Adam Schiff, sleepy Joe Biden and the
whistle blower who miraculously disappeared
after I released the transcript of the call,
the second whistleblower who also disappeared
and the IgG be part of the list.
Another tweet about the whistleblower and
which hunt saying, quote, whatever happened
to the so-called and former to whistleblower
number one seems to have disappeared after
I released the capital T transcript of the
call.
Shouldn't he be on the list to testify?
Which hun?
And then of course the old stalwart presidential
harassment in all capital letters, which has
followers just love that one.
Getting 125,000 likes.
This is a tiny fraction of what Trump did
just on Saturday, 82 tweets.
How does he have this much time?
I mean, I guess he's barely doing anything
else and maybe that's a good thing.
But aside from the content of Donald Trump's
tweets, which are particularly embarrassing
and erratic, one would never imagined that
a president would have time to tweet 82 times
in one day about anything.
If you take the job seriously and you read
briefings and history and nonfiction and do
all of the things that many other presidents
have done, you don't have time for this stuff.
Now, as much as Barack Obama read and researched,
by the way, he still made mistakes on the
job.
So how does Trump even possibly stand a chance
if he spends his days tweeting?
And of course, once again, is the drug issue
in the background of this, this type of manic
over the top behavior.
Also common among abusers of stimulants.
Donald Trump, according to some who were behind
the scenes on the apprentice, snorts Adderall,
he's been pictured with a stack of Sudafed
in his desk at Trump tower, which can also
be crushed up and used in ways similar to
a all Adderall tweeting 82 times in a day
is another sign that is making people wonder
about stimulant abuse because it is not normal
behavior.
Nevermind, by the way, that he says he only
sleeps four hours per day and often is tweeting
in the middle of the night.
More signs of stimulant use, or maybe better
said abuse of stimulants.
Make sure you follow the David Pakman show
on Instagram or continued coverage of Trump's
tweets at David Pakman show.
While you're there, I ask you humbly follow
me on Instagram as well at Davidson.
Got packaged to